[Music]
you had no interaction with Letterman
when you got the neck right I mean you
met with him I guess a couple of times
just a sort of way to do his show I mean
we talked on the phone a few times and
he was nice to me at the beginning like
you know he was friendly and stuff
well friendlies too much he would stand
like you know Dave he would send a box
of meat at Christmas yeah yeah yeah
there's no interaction yeah but he but
he I think Dave is a painfully awkward
yes and and I under I appreciate that I
understand what it is right and so I
talked to him on the air and we were
cordial but we were never friends and
it's funny here you were he was
technically your boss oh absolutely yeah
yeah you think it would have been like
hey let's go to dinner I'm gonna mentor
you a bit because I've been at the game
for a while if that's what we imagine
now behind the scenes that's a very
funny idea knowing David cuz I know you
know the idea that they would say let me
help you out here son and that's not who
he is
did you ever get an indication from
their camp that they were happy with
what you were doing yeah yeah yeah Rob
Burnett was always very good to me it
was a renegotiation about five years
under the deal and said this ransom we
can do to help her I said yeah a box of
used money and he sent me a box of used
money I was like I kept under my bed and
used it for like two years